to nas's university of el manar is
renowned its engineering school ranks
top in the country but for more than
half of the students graduation is
followed by unemployment with Tunisia's
economy struggling some students are
hoping for help from Europe see jose
luis auditorium uma no Martha and what
we want here are investors who can help
our country develop hablamos the
civilian have antalya but that's it
we're not looking for a handout
administrativo Mottola Mossad Millie
alejate see another atom we heard
Germany will assist us in the
educational sector but we don't want any
interference in our domestic affairs on
time ago I hope that the Foreign
Minister will bring serious offers and
ideas for German Tunisian cooperation
and investment yes death would I hope he
doesn't just give us a speech and forget
about us as soon as he leaves why didn't
see how you hold Romania for Maharaja
the German Foreign Minister frank-walter
steinmeier didn't announce any new
financial aid during his visit in his
speech at the University he appealed to
students to take the initiative
themselves flying above all it all comes
down to you the Indian ideas for new
products are needed ideas for new
products and projects and the
perseverance and hard work to achieve
them Zoe Project it's of a victory many
Tunisians including President baiji ke
Essebsi are hoping for more than just
words from Germany as a model of
democracy in the Arab world Tunisia has
a lot at stake